los representantes de la oficina
nacional de procesos electorales me han
dicho que no habrá prórroga y los
comicios combinan sí o sí a las siete de
esta noche porque después de esto se
tiene previsto el traslado de las actas
electorales para el conteo de votos esta
situación ha generado molestia en muchos
peruanos debo señalar que en el lugar
donde a mí me tocó ir a sufragar las
elecciones comenzaron con dos horas de
retraso
allí conversé con algunos electores y
ellos se quejaron por las largas filas y
también por lo que denominaron un
desorden en medio de la pandemia del cob
y 19 francisco que es lo que han
establecido entonces las autoridades
las autoridades han hecho un llamado a
los peruanos y han solicitado
voluntarios para que ellos realicen la
labor de miembros de mesa ante muchos
que fueron sorteados para ejercer tal
función y no se presentaron entonces el
presidente francisco sagasti luego de ir
a sufragar hizo un llamado a los
peruanos para que acudan y se cumplan
con el deber cívico el mandatario
prometió que los comicios serán
transparentes y que a partir de las 11 y
30 de la noche la oficina nacional de
procesos electorales dará a conocer los
primeros resultados oficiales pero en
paralelo la defensoría del pueblo ha
señalado que se ha producido un mal
desempeño durante la votación de los
adultos mayores el organismo que vigila
los derechos de la ciudadanía ha
señalado que va a emitir un reporte
detallando más incidencias que se han
desplegado a lo largo de estas
elecciones también a través de las redes
y algunos ciudadanos se quejaron de que
ellos se encontraron algunas ánforas
llenadas con los recuadros que
corresponderían a los candidatos es
decir ánforas con votos que ya estaban
ya realizados cuando todavía no se
habían producido la apertura de algunos
centros de sufragio estas y otras
situaciones van a ser analizadas por las
autoridades y sabremos bueno a partir de
las 11 y 30 de la noche quiénes son los
principales candidatos que van a estar
presentes en la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones que se va a realizar el
próximo 6 de junio